je vous le disais dans les titres les
déplacements des membres du gouvernement
se succèdent dans nos départements
une semaine après venue de la ministre
de l'industrie en indre-et-loire
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de gabrielle
attal le porte parole du gouvernement de
faire une étape à blois
alors que dès demain tous les français
de 18 à 55 ans qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques nous vont pouvoir se faire
vacciner
le secrétaire d'état est venu à rappeler
que la vaccination est l'une des clés de
cette sortie de crise plus
d'explications avec romain delville et
lucas chopin la visite de gabriella
talent à blois est à l'image des
annonces faites hier par emmanuel macron
le porte parole du gouvernement s'est
d'abord rendu ici au centre de
vaccination du jeu de paume où il a
évoqué l'accès au vaccin dès demain pour
les personnes en surcharge pondérale
sévère et ses premiers mots dans ce
centre ont été pour le personnel
mobilisé pour mener à bien cette
campagne il faut vraiment très
simplement prestement voix vous
remercier pour cette mobilisation qui
vous dire que ont fait évidemment pour
notre part tout ce qu'on peut pour faire
venir le plus de doses possible en
france parce que c'est ça aujourd'hui le
facteur limitant pour aller encore plus
loin
mais les doses arrive va pouvoir
continuer à étendre la campagne de
vaccination secrétaire d'état poursuivie
par une visite du château royal de blois
le château comme les autres musées
français pour accueillir du public à
partir du 19 mai c'est elisabeth la
trémolières qui l'a accueilli et qui lui
a offert une visite succincte de
l'établissement la conservatrice en chef
du château royal s'est dit ravi de ce
nouveau calendrier
le travail d'un conservateur s'est pas
seulement de la recherche
c'est encore et surtout de diffuser de
communiquer les collections les
monuments le patrimoine le communiqué le
faire aimer et à des visiteurs voilà
donc la connaîtra dans notre adn et dans
nos missions fondamentales y est quand
même les visiteurs donc le contact les
visiteurs dont on est tous ravis de
pouvoir ouvrir gabriela talent a conclu
sa journée blésoise dans un bistrot de
la ville comme les autres bars
restaurants il sera autorisée à servir
en terrasse le 19 mai les stades
intérieur elles rouvriront le 9 juin et
les restaurateurs présents aujourd'hui
ont exprimé quelques réserves et réclamé
plus de précisions notamment au sujet
des jauges mais gabriel attal la sueur
des réponses seront apportées d'ici
quelques jours
la semaine prochaine se tiendront
des concertations sous l'égide de chaque
ministre avec les secteurs concernés et
le premier ministre aura l'occasion dans
une conférence de presse la semaine du
10 mai de faire des annonces plus
précises sur les règles et les
protocoles de réouverture le calendrier
du déconfinement annoncées par le
gouvernement s'étale jusqu'au 30 juin
c'est normalement à cette date que
prendront fin couvre-feu et restrictions
pour autant gabriela talent l'a rappelé
aujourd'hui des freins d'urgence
pourrait être actionné localement dans
les territoires où le virus circulera
encore trop rapidement